durante el fin de semana de Acción de
Gracias el presidente byden no hizo
declaraciones ni escribió trinos sobre
las protestas en China tampoco lo
hicieron Anthony blinken secretario de
estado Ni Jake Sullivan asesor nacional
de seguridad sin embargo en la rueda de
prensa diaria de la Casa Blanca
comunicaciones del Consejo de Seguridad
nacional dijo que Estados Unidos apoya
el derecho a la protesta pacífica en
todo el mundo incluyendo para los
ciudadanos de la República popular China
y agregó que yo bailén ya está al tanto
de la situación al respecto marco Rubio
senador por la Florida criticó en un
comunicado la cobardía con la que la
administración de Joe biden está
abordando el tema y defendiendo a los
ciudadanos chinos sin embargo
analistas citados por medios nacionales
acá en Estados Unidos dicen que un
pronunciamiento más fuerte más Severo
por parte de Washington puede usarse en
Beijing Como un pretexto de
interferencia y desviar la tensión del
problema que está generando las
protestas